ان تخرج الاداره الامريكيه عن صمتها ازاء
ممارسات اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين فذلك يعني
ان الحليف الوثيق لواشنطن تخطى حدود ما
يمكن تفهمه او تحمله لكن ورغم الخطوه
النادره باستدعاء الخارجيه الامريكيه
للسفير الاسرائيلي وتحذيره من مخاطر
التصعيد فان الاحتلال يمضي قدما في
اجراءاته على الارض وعلى صعيد التصريحات
السياسيه هذه جنازه الشهيد امير عماد ابو
خديجه قائد مجموعه الرد السريع كتيبه
طولكرم الذي اغتالته قوات الاحتلال يوم
الخميس في مدينه طولكرم شمال الضفه
الغربيه الاغتيال الجديد يندرج ضمن حمله
التصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر من اقتحامات
للمدن والبلدات فضفات الغربيه
امنيات الضفه في اول ايام شهر رمضان سجلت
ايضا عمليات اعتقال اسرائيليه في طول كرم
اخرى اذ اكد نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان
الاعتقالات تمت في الخليل ونابلس وبيت لحم
ورام الله وجنين حيث اتهمت قوه عسكريه من
جيش الاحتلال عددا من منازل الفلسطينيين
وعبثت بمحتوياتها قبل اقتيادها الموقوفين
الى مراكز للتحقيق معهم بتهمه مقاومه
الاحتلال ولا يزال التصعيد الاسرائيلي في
مرمى الانتقادات الدوليه لا سيما بعد
اقرار الكنيست قانونا يسمح للمستوطنين
بالعوده الى اربع مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه اخليت عام 2005 وهي جانيم وكاديم
وحوميش وسنور
نشعر بقلق عميق ازاء الالغاء الاخير
لقانون فك الارتباط لعام 2005 من طرف
الكنيست هذا القرار هو اجراء اخر احادي
الجانب يضر باي جهود متجدده لخفض التصعيد
ويقوض حل الدولتين
قبل ذلك شجب مجلس الامن الدولي تصعيد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتوسع الاستيطاني
في الضفه وبناء وحدات سكنيه جديده في
مستوطنات قائمه وحذر مندوب الدول الاعضاء
من التداعيات الخطيره لتلك الافعال على
الامن والسلم وعلى حل الدولتين الذي يقره
المجتمع الدولي